three guys were arrested today because
of a single tweet which exposed them for
insider trading but before we interview
the man responsible for all this chaos
let me just say
this might be the single and only
positive use of twitter ever here i
thought it was a place for mentally ill
people like myself to seek attention and
validation but apparently you can also
get people arrested which is pretty cool
because the department of justice and
fbi link a tweet in their indictment as
if it was the thing that got the
scooby-doo gang together now as happy as
i am that the blue bird solved the case
i have to say it feels a bit strange
that the fbi is monitoring twitter to
catch actual criminals and it sort of
begs the question
what's the real future of police work
i'm sure a lot of people join up
thinking they're going to be raiding
houses but maybe the future is you're
raiding minecraft houses maybe you build
your career by busting a metaverse mafia
i mean i guess on the one hand it's a
good sign they're paying attention to
what's going on out there on the other
hand it turns out when you look into
this that the insider trading going on
was actually pretty well known about and
that's why i brought on the man
responsible for all of this kobe he's a
podcaster famous crypto guy but most
importantly he's the twitter tweeter who
got these guys locked up and i was
hoping he could sort of get me to the
bottom of this help me figure out how he
found out about it but the first thing
he told me was actually that he was a
bit disappointed in how things were
being handled and thought that maybe
people were focusing on the wrong issue
how's it going how are you your tweet
got someone arrested i mean how does
that feel
yeah i mean actually i don't feel great
about that because the person i was
criticizing is not the person that got
arrested the person that got arrested uh
it seems like collateral damage i was
criticizing the institution that the
person i got arrested worked for and i
know the person that got arrested was
doing something very silly and criminal
and uh illegal but yeah i guess that is
what happened they got arrested
it seemed like from my conversation with
him kobe was more upset at the
institution coinbase where this happened
than at the front runner themselves this
is despite coinbase's ceo coming out
today saying that they were part of the
reason that this guy got arrested they
cooperated with the feds etc but kobe
doesn't see it this way coinbase at
least for a long time hasn't been the
solution
they've been the problem coinbase has
had listings front-running issues for a
while originally they only listed like
bitcoin and they had this policy that
were like they were only gonna list like
the best of the best and then as time
passed and we got to like the last
couple of years and meme stocks became
uh a thing and um obviously they went
public they started losing market share
so they they sort of changed their
policy and started listing like real
real real garbage but at the same time
they started having a lot of issues
around people buying the garbage they
were listing beforehand so people were
making money on coinbase front running
these trades for years they would just
find out whatever coinbase was going to
list buy it up before it listed and sell
it immediately after in fact it turns
out it was such a problem that coinbase
tried to address this issue at the time
but with no success then they published
this blog post about how they're going
to change um all their listening
processes so that this stuff cannot
happen in the future and they can get
better controls around it and then the
very next listing every single coin got
front run once again and i'm in a little
group of like um crypto people who like
look at interesting blockchain stuff and
someone like sent this ether scan link
and said hey has anyone looked into
looked into this i think these things
are going to get listed on coinbase
because they all got bought again by a
person who front run successfully last
time has anyone looked into does anyone
know what any of these are some of them
seem like really really garbage i think
one of them was called the food or
something i looked at that link i waited
for the coins to get added about eighty
percent of the ones that were bought on
this day were added so then i tweeted
the
the
um screenshot of everything he purchased
um and the blog post like a few weeks
ago saying we're tightening up our
controls just to say like coinbase is
clearly incompetent at these issues
they're unable they're unable to stop it
no they've just done this whole song and
dance about how much they're going to
improve the ecosystem and how much they
care about like getting these things
right and the very next coin listing has
been front run wow this whole case
contradicts coinbase who claims that
they were actively monitoring for
illegal activity but honestly from the
looks of it it looks like the only thing
they were monitoring was twitter because
ultimately they didn't launch this
investigation until after someone had
proved it on the blockchain and it's
probably time we talk about this
investigation and the main guy arrested
in this case his name was ashan wahi and
he was an employee at coinbase who was
on the team responsible for listing the
new crypto tokens on the exchange he
insider traded by buying the coins he
knew they would be listing in a bit and
then after the price pumped he'd profit
by selling them which is obviously
illegal and market manipulation and the
only reason that there are three guys
listed in this indictment and three guys
who got arrested is because the employee
decided that he wanted his brother and
friend in on the scam he wanted to share
the wealth and share a jail cell i guess
in total they allegedly made 1.5 million
dollars which honestly are rookie
numbers let's be real guys you got to
pump those up i mean they're gonna go to
jail and guys are absolutely gonna be
laughing at them like you went to jail
for 1.5 million dollars in fraud like do
you need a baby bottle to go with your
itsy bitsy fraud this is sort of why i
find myself thinking that kobe's sort of
right here that maybe the most
interesting part of this case is not the
actual criminals but the system that
allowed this to even happen i don't
think a guy stealing 1.5 million dollars
over the course of 18 months
is even the interesting part of the
story the interesting part of the story
is for 18 months an institution had this
guy in charge of like coin listing stuff
was unable to identify that he was just
like stealing from people by front
running and then
anonymous users on
like the internet can find out about it
or i can tweet about it and then all of
a sudden there's an investigation into
it i just don't understand what
processes they have in place
for that to be how that works now to
that very important question what
processes are in place i think kobe's
forgetting about the most important
process of all that clearly they have
abided by which is one that's even
trusted by the fbi you check twitter
although i don't want to just dunk on
the feds in coinbase here because it
does seem like they did a pretty good
job investigating and arresting the guy
after they found out what was happening
i'm talking about the main guy wahi
because according to the indictment
coinbase was supposed to interrogate him
when he suddenly decided to flee the
country he told them that he had a
medical emergency involving his father
while he then purchased an airline
ticket due to board only 11 hours later
to flee to india and somehow
they caught up i mean despite almost no
warning beforehand they arrested him
before he left the country so
bravo to that that's pretty awesome that
they were able to do that but i also
hope we're not learning the wrong
lessons here where we just punish a few
guys for crimes that have been going on
for years
only after someone tweets about it i
mean what's next are we going to make
some tick tock deputies some instagram
enforcers i guess i get the irony that
i'm the internet detective here saying
that but um i do ultimately think there
probably should be a division between
influencers and law enforcement i don't
think those worlds should collide very
often but
every now and then it does